I was asked how the youth in the Arab
world can make a difference and I I
would like to say that they just have to
be who they are and do exactly what they
have been doing they've been teaching my
generation many many things faith love
hope and and the true desire for freedom
their bravery is absolutely tremendous I
feel that dignity is at hand again
humanity is at hand life itself is at
hand through the great sacrifices of our
young people I believe that it is us
people who are of my age and older who
have to ask youth on how it is that we
must live and how it is that we must
aspire they have been a tremendous
inspiration and the tremendous school of
humility bravery and wisdom may God
bless them and bless this region bless
our countries today is a great joyful
day for Libya today is the day of
liberation congratulations to all these
young people who have made this
revolution possible and our condolences
and deepest feelings of sorrow and
sadness and and and good wishes for all
the people who have suffered through
this for all the mothers for all the
children of the martyrs and the families
of the injured may God bless them heal
them with the healing of love and
compassion thank you very much may God
bless